when you fight Jermaine Taylor that was
160 right yes yeah dude I was one fight
where I remember getting angry at larry
merchant larry merchants calling a fight
on my east night he wasn't recognizing
that you were tuning him up and you were
hurting them and you got like he was he
was commenting on a almost like is a
trend that he expected to see rather
than what was actually happening it was
a lot of things about that fight I loved
them guys because believe it or not in
my opinion that was a great fight and I
seen that day had that fight in a
top-ten middleweight one of the top 10
mill away fights of all time and that's
kind of a cool thing but also you know
some of that commentating note really
made that fight especially at the end my
opinion made that flight kind of what it
was also you know besides the fact me
getting dropped and everything but um
you know I didn't agree with the judging
of it you know class no one had me ahead
I went back and watched it I'm not one
of those egotistical people either like
I like to really break down what
happened in that fight and I and if I
lost around I would say I lost around
you know I was hard on myself with that
I watched a fight now probably 10 times
and I don't see where they had remained
winning you know yeah I gave him one
round and plus the ten eight so that's a
total of three rounds
and I don't see how that happened well
you know I mean we've had this
conversation a hundred times in this
podcast judging and boxing and judging
and MMA judging is just terrible yeah
it's just tear it's one it's sad it
doesn't make any sense there's so many
experts out there there's so many really
reliable people that you can call on
that would do a great job of figuring
out what's going on in a fight and for
whatever reason they don't get those
jobs I think they got to start doing
something soon in boxing with that yeah
they have to figure something out with
the judging the charlo fight yes yeah
yeah there's a handful of people I had
the argument with that actually thought
Charlie lost I didn't think that he
looked as good as he could have enough
light yeah but I thought he won the
fight
you know 116-112 but I don't know what
system they could try to break down for
that or try to get to actually start
making someone in fights fair but boxing
is doing fantastic to past two years I
mean the numbers are crazy you see him
with his own
Canelo and yeah so it's it's they're
just tensions at the sport and
popularity of it's coming back but what
could eventually hurt it again is things
like the the judging of the fights
yeah outcomes well there's certain ones
where you wanted like you want a
criminal investigation like Tim Bradley
Manny Pacquiao that was one where after
that was up I was like I was looking at
the TV I was looking to the side I was
looking at where I was like what the
[ __ ] did I just see what just happened
here that fight right there I actually
had to walk away with my head down I
thought that was probably one of the
worst robberies that I've ever seen
horrible robbery
I searched to give Tim Bradley two
rounds I gave him one I was trying to
give him rounds to Kyle like say how
where did you get to set B in other
words and I couldn't do it yeah I loved
him Bradley too by the way awesome guy
awesome awesome fighter too I mean he's
just all hard because he's amazing but
that just was a bad decision and you
know I think there was a there was a
lady that was responsible for two really
bad decisions or yeah a bird was it her
was it was there's another one too there
was an oddly bird she does haven't made
to I want to say yeah Letterman's
daughter baby well there was no there
was another lady who retired from doing
it after that decision it was like a big
controversy people were that her her
score was so off people would thinking
she got paid off just so many anymore
though it's hard to keep up with it yeah
but the thing is and in people that are
cynical or skeptical do you know how
much money is being bet on fights
especially a Manny Pacquiao fight
there's so much money and if someone
like Pacquiao is a prohibitive favorite
heading 210 proudly fight I mean who
knows it could be 4 to 1 5 to 1 6 to 1
somebody rolls up with a nice brown bag
we got in here it's $30,000 I never have
to report I think just yeah there's more
behind why that happens to you has to be
that's always been again the idea that
there's no bribery going on anymore
it's crazy I don't want to say it but I
think I have yeah I think I have an idea
you know I think it comes down to
who's putting the show on mm-hmm and
who's in the pocket but Teddy Atlas was
explaining it to when he was on the
podcast one of the things that he was
saying was that they take these people
out to dinner like like they're all in
cahoots and friendly with each other and
if there's a certain result that the
promoter would like to see these judges
will lean towards that if they have a
good relationship with that promoter you
said it for me yeah that's what it did
look teddy laid it out and I don't know
yeah it's bad because a given box is
really coming back it is and the fights
you got three or four weight classes
right now that's so interesting but the
bad part about it is you don't get
interested in it or you don't get as
excited anymore because you're afraid of
the outcome of the fight yeah you know